To do this, we'll need to add a counter. The counter will be incremented every
time you look at a word, not only when we find a long word, because we want to
count how many short words come before the long word. Let's try to hand trace a
little bit and see if this would work. If the first word is longer than nine
characters, that would mean we would want to return a position of zero. So we
would go into the loop, we would find the word, we would go into the if
statement because the word length would be longer than nine. We would mark the
word as found. And then we would increment position to one. Okay, that's not
quite right, so, maybe this we'll need to start at negative one. So that'll fix
it for the case where the first word is long. What if the first word is short,
and the second word is long? We'll start with position as -1, go into the while
loop. There are more words, and it's not found yet. We read the word. The word
is short, so we skip past the if statement and increment the position to zero.
Now we go back into the loop. There are more words, and we still haven't found
it. We read the second word, which is long so we go into the if statement, set
longWord to be the word that we just read, and say that we found it. Then
update the position which was previously zero, so now it'll be one, and then
get back to the while loop. But we
[UNKNOWN]
found so we break out, this should work, but I forgot to print it. Alright it
looks like the first long word in Alice in Wonderland is Adventures and its
position is one. Let's compare this to the text. It looks like Adventures in
position one and it's no wonder it would be related to the book, it's part of
the title.